hello and welcome to this video playing
Fabrizio's from Italy yeah I don't think
that the win would get me the all-time
high his rating is a bit too low for
that but let's see what happens um
copter a modern benoni here playing the
classical variation here with 92 let's
see what is he going forward this place
probably 45 I know this one yeah this
this was recently was seen in this idea
was seen in them I roni on kawana okay I
still do this and no nights for right
there Bonilla Corona was a little bit
different ok so here a five I guess I'm
a five look like it's probably okay
even with a simple b5 he should probably
be okay my development is not that
brilliant looks a bit wrong to put it
there it's unprotected this I don't like
but I don't see a tactic
Queen d2 bush about six Samson plan like
that would be okay I was really
expecting b5 now but maybe as second
second thoughts now as a success a week
oh that's sophisticated night wants to
go to the seven I guess
hmm interesting I have some interesting
options here even before it's
interesting well it's a very loose kind
of move okay I shouldn't shouldn't take
any longer 97 f-4s not a good idea ok
this was the idea anyway here's some and
let's do this green on c2 wasn't doing
much anyway getting out of this 95 with
tempo
threatening be for now which you
probably will prevent somehow probably
with the Queen move 27 something like
that looks okay all this one has also
wager to handle it I'm getting a lot of
potential and checks them I want to be
able to move the bishop that he without
him having a check on deform okay um
here I was thinking Bishop f4 but maybe
bishop age 6
not sure about it but I think it could
be a slight improvement if he moves the
bishop to someone some some less optimal
square to age a door to have six I don't
think you should trade it
it allows me to trade it would be quite
surprised Bishop f6 there's also Queen
to f4 as a potential move again it
doesn't it doesn't look good
taking a long time here Queen to d4 Wow
interesting move okay I cannot take
their taking on d4 no that's also wrong
and I have to move the Queen 24 was very
interesting with and my pieces look o
pieces look look a bit uncoordinated but
i'm not sure about all the same it's
active for him but he also has lots of
weaknesses a six now for example it's
tough to tough to defend 93 however you
can do this still it senseless king okay
bishop be sure to them
tough position very tough and now I can
move my bishop also 2g for over two is
six is got 95 this is an issue okay I'll
have to take is now this one so night c5
desrook a seven and i'm just checking d6
here
he allows that okay seven stuff I can't
just go through be soon okay so he he
basically says that 93 is so such a big
issue maybe it is i was thinking i have
f five but night b3 is is is a problem
is a real problem might be three queen a
form of this one for rookie one
and 93 oh my god when I was very strong
93 is probably just winning here I don't
see how I defend against the snow this
one I am just lost check Wow check black
resigns how lucky can you get oh my
goodness yeah i think i'm just some are
destined to get this all-time high now I
just can't just got outplayed him I mean
okay somewhere around here I think white
is ok but from here it all went downhill
and wow I have a hard time to believe
that this is okay for black but I always
have this hard time in this kind of the
Nonis where blacks position is basically
consisting our region these are so many
weaknesses but probably it doesn't
really matter because it's so active
well it's probably okay I mean it
probably is give 1c4 yeah f4 seems to be
a mistake an engine wants to take this
and gives us this equal
Queen f2 is amazing I don't have this
check which is very important like it's
very active I know 95 b3 i know i'm
already in bad shape the engine already
gives black win okay now and i have no
moves now is simply have no moves and d2
and this is minus a million i was
surprised at queen d 3 and this looked
completely crushing threatening this and
died f2 yeah this is was I simply have
no Musa yeah I know it just has to take
on g6 I mean okay this also wins of
course but now some some move that it's
not allowing the maid Queenie oneness is
the simplest one Jan Jan this is this is
made very good game i black but somehow
yeah just just one mistake did the trick
okay thanks for watching